one of the world's richest people is
officially running for president but he
won't be on the ballot in the early
contests that are considered critical
for most of his rivals Michael Bloomberg
the former Republican mayor of New York
launched his Democratic Party campaign
with millions of dollars worth of TV ads
ed O'Keefe is covering campaign 2020 at
good morning so what's behind this late
start strategy from Bloomberg money
money money money money he has more of
it than any other candidate so he
doesn't have some of the hurdles that
the others do after initially ruling on
a run earlier this year Bloomberg is
officially in running as a moderate
Democrat whether some think he's too
wealthy or too old or too late to join
the fray Bloomberg believes he has the
best shot of beating the other New
Yorker in the race President Trump he
could have just been the middle class
kid who made good but Mike Bloomberg
became the guy who did good former New
York Mayor Michael Bloomberg kicked off
his White House bid this weekend with a
new campaign ad now he's taking on
to rebuild a country the week-long ad
blitz rollout in at least 46 states and
cost a record-breaking 34 million
dollars and the multi-billionaire is
promising not to take any campaign
contributions and won't accept a salary
if he wins the White House bloomberg a
Republican turned independent turned
Democrat declined to run in 2016 in
September he told CBS this morning he
wouldn't join the 2020 primary while
former Vice President Joe Biden led the
field it was not a road for me when Joe
was in the race to get through because
we would have split the votes but that
was then polls now show an increasingly
fluid primary with mine and essentially
locked in a four-way race with Indiana
mayor Pete Buda judge and liberal
senators Elizabeth Warren and Bernie
Sanders Biden welcomed Bloomberg's entry
this weekend competition but other
Democrats were critical it does not mean
billionaires buying elections or just
because they are billionaires
thinking they can run for president
there are some big hurdles ahead for the
mayor in addition to likely skipping the
first two nominating states in the
Democratic primary refusing campaign
donations means he won't meet Democratic
National Committee rules to qualify for
primary debates his team says if the
rules change he'll gladly participate in
just in a few moments ago he will make
his first campaign stops today in
Norfolk Virginia we mentioned that he's
wealthy that 34 million he's putting
into ad buys that is the equivalent of
the average American based on his net
worth equivalent of the average American
writing a check for $39 small change
small change for a guy worth glad you
write someone's back Jack that was a
very analytical guy he wouldn't be doing
this unless he saw a pathway absolutely
and remember he has analyzed this since
2008 so finally after all these years he
thinks there must be an opening all
right ed thanks